bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat tout l'été je vous
propose de voir ou de revoir les temps
forts de la dernière session
parlementaire
vous le savez à la fin de l'année se
tiendra à paris la coop 21 la 21e
conférence des nations unies sur le
changement climatique
objectif de cette conférence parvenir à
un accord contraignant entre les
différents états participants afin
qu'ils s'engagent à réduire leurs
émissions de gaz à effet de serre cela
pour limiter le réchauffement climatique
à 2 degrés celsius
c'est un sujet sur lequel le parlement
est en pointe
en effet ce sera ensuite au parlement de
traduire au niveau national ces
engagements mondiaux et c'est pourquoi
le sénat est en première ligne sur la
coop 21 dans le cadre de la préparation
de cette conférence
ils ont auditionné laurence tubiana
l'ambassadrice chargée des négociations
climatiques tout de suite donc retour à
cette audition
nous sommes très heureux d'accueillir
aujourd'hui madame toubiana qui est
ambassadrice chargée des négociations
sur le changement climatique et la
représentante spéciale pour la
conférence marie climat 2004
l'ambassadrice nous sommes très heureux
de vous accueillir un petit peu moins de
200 jours de cette conférence sont très
heureux parce que nous savons que nul
mieux que vous ne peut nous faire le
point sur l'état de préparation de cette
conférence au combien importante et sur
ses chances de succès quelques mots pour
vous dire que
le sénat est très mobilisé sur la
préparation de cette conférence
parce que nous sommes bien conscients
que c'est une conférence qui est
importante bien sûr pour la france
puisque c'est la france qui accueille
cette conférence mais elle est surtout
importante pour la planète et plus
encore pour l'humanité puisque comme le
dit souvent nicolas hulot c'est pas la
planète qui est en cause c'est
l'humanité nous mesurerons déjà un
certain nombre d'effets des dérèglements
climatiques y compris dans des pays
comme comme le nôtre avec la montée des
océans avec des phénomènes d'érosion des
côtes avec des événements climatiques
extrêmes de plus en plus fréquents nous
irons d'ailleurs dans pas très longtemps
sur la côte bordelaise voir les effets
de l'érosion des côtes dans cette dans
cette région et donc c'est pour cela que
le sénat est très mobilisé gérard
larcher présentera demain à la presse
les actions que le sénat entend mener
dans les semaines qui viennent et qu'il
a commencé à mener parce que nous avons
eu la semaine dernière un très
intéressant colloque sur les religions
et le réchauffement climatique était
extrêmement intéressant nous recevons
ici chaque fois qu'il y à des
parlementaires étrangers qui sont en
france nous les recevons pour faire le
point avec eux et pour essayer quand
c'est nécessaire de les sensibiliser
nous avons pour la semaine passée reçu
des parlementaires canadiens nous avions
hier des staffeurs américains avec
lesquels nous avons eu des échanges très
intéressants et bien sûr nous
participons à la mobilisation des
territoires puisque le sénat vous le
savez la chambre qui représente les
territoires et que les territoires sont
ont un rôle aussi important en terme de
deux maîtrises d des émissions des gaz à
effet de serre et puis je dois dire un
mot sur la préparation de la journée de
lui paie journée de l'union
interparlementaire qui aura lieu au
sénat le 6 décembre et qui réunira des
parlementaires des différents états ce
fut le cas à lima et nous allons au
cours de cette réunion présenter une
résolution j'ai été nommé rapporteur de
cette résolution lors de l'assemblée
jean-louis paix et nous aimerions
vraiment que cette déclaration qui sera
celle des parlementaires et des
parlementaires des parlements pardon
puisse figurer dans les actes finaux de
la conférence
je le dis parce que c'est vrai on a
ressenti à lima pour ceux qui étaient
certains parlementaires n'ont reçu aussi
dans d'autres circonstances les
parlements les parlementaires ont trop
souvent le sentiment d'être un peu à
l'écart de ces grandes négociations
je sais que c'est pas votre volonté
puisque vous m'avez déjà dit vous leur
direz peut-être aujourd'hui que c'est
important que les parlementaires se
mobilise auprès de leurs homologues
d'autres pays pour les sensibiliser pour
que les parlements respectifs des
différents pays puissent eux mêmes quand
c'est nécessaire
faire pression sur les gouvernements jeu
je rappelle qu'aujourd'hui au moment où
on se parle il n'y a que cudi
contributions qui ont été fournis pour
la conférence de décembre alors que
normalement elle devait tout être
fournis pour la fin du la fin du mois de
mars
alors je voudrais que vous nous
indiquiez vraiment basse à driss si à
votre avis on a encore aujourd'hui des
chances sérieuses d'arriver à un
véritable accord à paris c'est à dire un
accord contraignant et universel nous
avons le sentiment comme je le disais
qu'il n'y a pas un enthousiasme
débordant puisque j'ai indiqué qu'il n'y
avait que 10 contribution qui avait été
fourni est ce que vous disiez il n'y a
pas très longtemps qu'une accélération
du processus était nécessaire est ce
qu'elle peut est ce qu'elles peuvent
venir je crois qu'il ya une une session
de négociations à beaune la semaine
prochaine est ce qu'on peut en attendre
et puis nicolas hulot que nous avons
reçu il ya quelques semaines nous a
parlé de d'une course contre la montre
alors où en est on dans cette dans cette
course
et puis comme je le disais tout à
l'heure on aimerait également que vous
puissiez nous indiquer en cours à nous
parlementaires nous pouvons
être utile nous pouvons encore être
utile et notamment auprès de quel pays
faut-il que nous sans trion notre action
pour faire en sorte de contribuer
modestement mais de contribuer quand
même à la réussite de cette conférence
merci à hervé madame l'ambassadrice
quelques mots rapides pour vous
souhaiter au nom de la commission des
affaires étrangères et notre président
jean pierre raffarin qui heureusement
retenu en séance publique
vous souhaitez de notre côté la
bienvenue et vous remercier d'avoir
accepté ces 30 content car nous savons
que votre agenda est particulièrement
chargé et votre implication dans ce
dossier est évidemment très importante
effectivement le calendrier parce nous
approchons de cette date fatidique
et comme notre collègue le président
m'aurait vous l'a dit le sénat a pris
l'initiative de s'impliquer au travers
de ses différentes délégations de ses
différentes compétences pour prendre
toute sa part dans la préparation de
cette conférence internationale qui
suscite beaucoup d'espoirs je rappelle
pour l'histoire que la conférence de
copenhague s'était terminé par un
résultat en demi-teinte avec des
déclarations particulière d'un certain
de pays en voie de développement qui
posait qui nous posait à nous pays
occidentaux des questions dérangeantes
et donc les mêmes questions demeurent du
reste mais peut-être aurez-vous à coeur
de nous expliquer comment les choses ont
pu avancer
comment la prise de conscience des
grands des grands enjeux visant à
maintenir sur terre un climat qui reste
supportable est favorable au
développement des populations et bien
comment ces défis peuvent être relevés
pour ce qui concerne la commission des
affaires étrangères
et de la défense nous nous sommes comme
je le disais il ya un instant mobilisés
notamment à travers un groupe de travail
qui est animé par cédric perrin qui
malheureusement n'est pas là mais aussi
par notre collègue et il a échoué à qui
j'aurais l'occasion de donner la parole
tout à l'heure après votre contribution
et qui se focalise notamment sur les
conséquences géopolitiques de la montée
des eaux et sur un sujet aussi tout à
fait passionnant dont on parle beaucoup
ces temps ci dure est la situation dans
l'arctique qui est un continent que nous
connaissons et que nous fréquentons -
mais qui pose aussi beaucoup de
questions pour l'avenir
hervé maurey rappelait la communication
de nicolas hulot qui était une
communication un peu contrastée dans
lequel il nous faisait part de sa
crainte ou en tous les cas de la fin
d'un certain nombre d'éléments de
satisfaction mais nous faisait part
aussi de ses craintes et notamment de
l'insuffisance du nombre des premières
contributions nationales qui devaient
étaient déposées avant je crois à la fin
mars et qui ne sont toujours pas est ce
que c est un retard administratif ou
bien est ce que c'est vous donner une
signification à ces retards est ce qu'il
ya des pays avec lequel les choses vont
mieux et d'autres moins bien
et puis surtout donc comment peut-on
mobiliser la société civile au niveau
mondial afin qu'un accord ne reste pas
lettre morte parce qu'il est toujours
facile de signer des accords
internationaux
encore faut-il que tous ces objectifs
soient partagées par nos populations et
que celle ci accepte parfois de faire
des sacrifices auxquels elles n'ont
point à l'habitude
je voudrais au passage rappelé que vous
posiez conseil d'administration de
l'agencé française de développement et
qu'à ce titre votre expérience dans ce
domaine-là la fréquentation
des pays en voie de développement et les
projets que l'afd mène dans ces pays
vous fait de vous une interlocutrice
tout à fait privilégié par rapport à ces
pays donc moi j'aimerais beaucoup pour
avoir été administrateur de l'afd avant
mon collègue henri de raincourt qui m'a
remplacé
j'aimerais beaucoup que vous puissiez
nous dire comment cette préparation de
la conférence s'effectue dans ces pays
qui ont des logiques et des
problématiques qui sont parfois
sensiblement différents des nôtres même
s'ils sont souvent aussi les pays qui
supportent le plus les conséquences de
ces des règles de ces dérèglements
climatiques
voilà quelques perspectives qui seront
certainement nourri par le jeu des
questions de nous coller encore une fois
nous vous remercions parce que nous
mesurons l'immensité de la tâche qui
vous incombent et votre engagement
personnel entier pour que au nom de la
france cette conférence soit un succès
donc sur l'ensemble de ces enjeux de
cette négociation
quel bilan peut-on faire au jour
d'aujourd'hui
voilà quelques thématiques qui je crois
nous rirons cette rencontre donc ils
vont vous permettre pendant une
quinzaine de minutes si vous le voulez
bien de de nous présenter une synthèse
et puis après rapporteur prendront la
parole et bien sûr nos collègues auront
la liberté de vous poser toutes les
questions dans le temps que vous nous
consacrer je vous remercie madame
l'ambassadrice vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup de cette
invitation
c'est toujours un moment important
devant un groupe comme le vôtre de
prendre un peu de recul par rapport à
j'ai toujours l'impression d'être un
garagiste dans avec les mains dans le
cambouis et de prendre un peu de recul
et se demander où on en est
effectivement un peu moins de 200 jours
avant avant la
l'étape finale si je puis dire vous avez
déjà l'un et l'autre posé beaucoup de
questions auxquelles je vais essayer de
répondre et peut-être en recadrant un
peu et je le fais d'autant plus que
laurent fabius n'a pas pu venir
devant vous expliquer la vision globale
de ce qu'on attend pour paris je vais
peut-être partir de là du point
d'arrivée pour essayer de revenir où
nous en sommes essayer de tracer le
chemin déjà parcouru et de chemin qui
reste à parcourir
et ce faisant répondre déjà me
semble-t-il à quelques interrogations
vous avez soulevé alors vous vous l'avez
sans doute entendu à la fois d'une
manière ou d'une autre de ministre des
affaires étrangères et du président de
la république d'une part de la président
de la république
l'idée qu' on cherche à paris en
tournant non pas seulement un compromis
de plus sur une longue route de
négociations qui durent depuis 1992 jeu
j'aime à dire toutefois que même si
cette période de négociation vous paraît
longue
les négociations sur la libéralisation
du commerce ont commencé en 1948
on peut estimer qu'elles étaient eux
très largement achevée il ya encore
beaucoup de secteurs sur lequel il ya du
travail en 1994 sur un sujet beaucoup
plus simple que celui du crime a donc 92
a aujourd'hui ça paraît long mais on est
c'est quand même moins long que ce qu'on
a déjà fait ce qu'on avait investit donc
passé sur le commerce et c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué juste pour se donner un
peu la difficulté d'accorder ce qui au
fond une évolution profonde non
seulement des politiques publiques
nationales mais aussi des modèles de
développement et c'est pour ça qu'on
cherche à paris à faire comprendre faire
sentir le fait qu' on est dans un
tournant que on faut que ce qu'on
cherche c'est à dire une économie très
sobre en carbone à terme très peu
fondée sur les ressources fossiles
notamment le charbon le pétrole ou le
gaz est on capable en tout cas n'est pas
aujourd'hui le cas de neutraliser ses
émissions de carbone dans l'atmosphère
et que donc on cherche à faut faire
converger des anticipations non
seulement des gouvernements et sont
évidemment très divers mais aussi d'un
certain nombre d'acteurs en particulier
les acteurs économiques mais aussi les
collectivités locales qui ont pris un
rôle très important dans cette
discussion sur le climat depuis bien des
années
faire converger 7 ses anticipations pour
partager au fond à la fois l'objectif
général vraiment faire changer les
modèles de développement pour qu'on
puisse rester sous la barre de
l'augmentation de température moyenne de
2 degrés par rapport à l'ère
préindustrielle il est du coup changé
profondément toute une série d'éléments
du développement économique
d'aujourd'hui sans pour autant renoncer
à ce développement
sans renoncer à la croissance économique
mais au fond des couples est
profondément les la consommation des
ressources fossiles
d'une certaine manière aussi un peu la
consommation d'énergie même si on peut
de plus en plus produire de l'énergie
propre par rapport au climat et la
croissance économique
donc cette convergence des anticipations
c'est au fond le jeu résultat qu'on
cherche à paris le 12 décembre on
aimerait voir dans les titres des
journaux ça s'exprime ration pas comme
ça de façon plus concrète
cette économie sobre en carbone apparaît
inévitable c'est ce qui va se passer
c'est ce que qui est souhaitable et
c'est ce qu'au fond tous les acteurs
présents financiers économiques
industriels
gouvernements ou autorités locales
pensent que c'est ce qu'il faut faire et
c'est ce qui va arriver et donc on
cherche ça et pour chercher ça cette
convergence des anticipations parce
qu'il ya une bonne partie comme vous le
disiez c'est la mise en oeuvre l'accord
c'est une chose mais surtout c'est
qu'est-ce qui se passe et qu'est ce qui
se passe est aussi ça dépend de la
conviction notamment des acteurs
économiques que c'est les marchés
nouveaux que c'est les solutions
technologiques sont à portée de main ou
que l'on voit comment les développer et
c'est une qu'on veut une conviction
mutuelle des pouvoirs publics et des
acteurs privés pour qu on aille dans ce
chemin
c'est pour ça qu'on présente là le
résultat de paris en quatre volets
l'accord lui-même c'est pour lequel la
france a reçu un mandat en acceptant de
temps candidate pour être l'hôte de la
force la coop 21 les contributions
nationales qui sont puisque nous sommes
dans un système qui est aujourd'hui en
appel par le bas c'est à dire que c'est
des pistes d action d engagement
volontaire des pays sur cette réduction
des émissions est aussi aussi dans
d'autres domaines
donc ça c'est le deuxième volet du
résultat de paris les la mobilisation
des finances et donc la modification au
fond des réponses que le système
financier offre aujourd'hui les besoins
d'investissements pour que ce système
financier dans les finances publiques
que les finances privées à répondre à ce
défi de la transition énergétique et
économique dans le monde vers ce monde
bas carbone et enfin les engagements des
acteurs non gouvernementaux car encore
une fois il faut construire cet effet de
croyance il faut montrer qu'il ya
beaucoup d'entreprises aujourd'hui qui
pensent que cette économie sobre en
carbone c'est l'avenir et qui
investissent qui pensent que l'économie
fondée sur les ressources fossiles
elle est risquée du point de vue
économique elle est aussi risqué parce
que elle elle a des conséquences en
matière d'impact depuis compris sur les
activités économiques du changement
climatique
c'est aussi le fait de vouloir montrer
que beaucoup d'autorités locales dont
dépendent beaucoup de décisions qui ont
un infraction le crime un notamment en
matière de planification urbaine
de politique de transport de enfin toute
la liste de ce que font les autorités
locales qu'elle aussi elle voit dans ces
villes durables danser dans ses plans de
réduction d'émissions ou d'adaptation au
changement climatique l'avenir de leur
collectivité et donc on voudrait qu'à
paris l'alliance de l'action pour le
climat l'eau le slogan de la cap 21
s'est unissent dans l'action pour le
climat et qu'on m'a va matérialiser sur
l'idée d'un concept d'alliance de paris
pour le climat et cette alliance à
représente à la fois le travail
juridique qu'on doit faire l'accord
c'est décision nationale souveraine de
s'engager dans ce modèle de
développement et le la réponse du
système financier et enfin donc les
engagements des acteurs non
gouvernementaux et donc en partie qu en
pratique on a forcément du coup
puisqu'on veut c4 résultat une
diplomatie j'appelle ça à 360° parce que
l'on doit à la fois travailler avec les
gouvernements à différents niveaux chefs
d'état ministres négociateurs on doit
travailler je dirais non pas avec ceux
qui négocient seulement mais ceux qui
sont dans les pays en train de
construire les politiques énergétiques
des différents pays
enfin on doit aussi travailler avec des
acteurs du système financier
et enfin on doit aussi déployer
développer un site et ses acteurs non
gouvernementaux qui veulent s'engager à
le faire de façon compréhensible
vérifiables aussi pour que cela donne
confiance à tout le monde donc on a une
diplomatie sur tous ces éléments on est
évidemment puissamment aidé par un
réseau diplomatique qui reste
exceptionnel
à l'échelle mondiale une mobilisation
sans précédent de ce réseau diplomatique
je crois que un grand étonnement de mes
collègues négociateur il n'avait jamais
vu avant un ambassadeur de france là il
le rencontre en général tous les mois et
demi
parfois ils trouvent que c'est même
beaucoup quoi et donc on a dans les
ambassades dans chaque poste
une mobilisation en direction des
négociateurs et les ministres mais aussi
des collectivités locales des industries
est donc mobilisation 360 degrés
et peut-être maintenant en venir ou
est-ce qu'on en est alors vous m'avez
tendu une perche en disant est ce qu'on
voit ce qu'on en est loin puisqu'on a
que 10 contribution 37 ans comptant
évidemment les pays de l'union
alors pourquoi ça ne l'inquiète pas
outre mesure le 31 mars qu'était la date
une date de pour les pays qui peuvent le
faire fixer à lima donc ce n'était pas
une date obligatoire la date butoir
aller au moins d'octobre
l'exercice est très compliqué jean
discuté hier avec la secrétaire
exécutive de la commission économique
pour l'amérique latine continent qui
s'est beaucoup mobilisée pour le climat
et dans les pays peine à rédiger leur
contribution en lice ya barcena me
disais c'est une prise de conscience
très très très importante entre dire
qu'on veut faire quelque chose sur le
climat et commencer à se dire en 2025 en
comment je vais réduire les émissions
comment je vais le faire dans le secteur
de l'énergie dans le secteur des
transports dans le secteur dans le
secteur industriel est ce que j'utilise
des instruments politiques fiscales
est-ce que je me fixe un objectif de
réduction absolue des émissions
tout ça est quelque chose pour beaucoup
de pays qui étaient pas fait qu'il
n'avait jamais été fait et il est normal
et quand je vois un peu la nature de la
préparation de la contribution chinoise
qui va être très détaillé c'est aussi
comme ici quand on a les amendements à
la loi transition énergétique c de même
nature
même si la portée du regard va pas tout
à fait aussi loin mais enfin 2025 ou
2030 ses tresses et un ces noms comme
horizon air essais débats cas de
politique dans chaque pays qui sont
extrêmement fortes il ya évidemment les
protestations des industriels s'ils
pensent que ça va gêner leur
développement ce qui les agriculteurs ou
ou des forestiers qui ont peur que ça
enfin vous imaginez tous les débats et
partout il y à des débats intenses à la
fois la prise de conscience des
gouvernements que il s'agit plus d'un
espèce de chose un peu abstraite que
c'est très concret ça va se traduire ça
doit se traduire dans la politique
domestique et que c'est en même temps
très très compliqué donc c'est normal
que ça prenne du temps c'est des
arbitrages complexe financier sur le au
fond le taux de croissance espéré sur
comment on va faire enfin 2 et donc au
contraire moi je ne suis pas pessimiste
sur l'engagement des pays à présenter
des contributions je crois qu'on aura
beaucoup beaucoup peut-être pas 195
contribution à paris mais on aura très
largement les 99.99 recouvrant les
émissions mondiales de gaz à effet de
serre qui seront comprises dans ces
contributions et une bonne partie vont
arriver dans les semaines qui viennent
les autres pendant l'été et je crois
qu'en octobre on aura en tout cas de
quoi voir où nous en sommes alors
sûrement nicolas hulot a partagé son ses
inquiétudes sur la nature de ces
contributions pour et ce pour ce qu'on
en sait elles ne pourront pas en tout
cas à l'horizon 2025 ou 2030 répondre à
la question est ce qu'on est sur la
bonne trajectoire pour respecter
l'objectif collectif qu'on s'est donné
qui sera réaffirmée à paris celui de ne
pas dépasser cette augmentation des 2
degrés par rapport à l'ère
préindustrielle c'est vrai ces
contributions sera encore plus
ambitieuse que précédemment
bien plus ambitieuse que précédemment
mais sans doute insuffisante et c'est
donc tout le tout l'enjeu de l'accord de
paris de prévoir comment on rattrape
progressivement cette trajectoire qui
est compatible avec deux grecques et
très c'est une trajectoire sévères en
matière d'émissions mondiales il faut
pas oublier que c'est au moins 50% de
réduction des émissions mondiales par
rapport à 90 en 2050 nous mêmes par
rapport à 2000 ce qui est à peu près
équivalent
c'est donc une grande transformation 1
ça veut dire que les pays beaucoup de
pays en développement commencent à
réduire leurs émissions de façon absolue
évidemment c'est ce que la chine a
accepté en principe mais encore faut-il
qu'elles que ça sera suffisamment tôt et
suffisamment fort c'est à dire que la
descente ensuite des émissions soient
significatives
donc on a plein d'enjeux qui explique à
la fois la difficulté de venir avec des
propositions concrètes rapidement et
en même temps le sentiment que j'ai que
tous veulent le faire et veulent le
faire le plus sérieusement possible
de ce point de vue voilà où on en est je
pense que on aura un meilleur tableau
déjà d'ici quelques semaines
certainement donc entre le 1er et le 15
ou le 20 juin et une nouvelle vague qui
vont arriver dans le courant de l'été
dans le courant du mois d'août ou du
début du mois de septembre
alors où est ce qu'on en est sûre les
grands points de la négociation peut
être un petit peu de de technologies de
négociation comment est ce qu'on fait
vous savez qu être président de la
conférence des parties
en principe nous prenons cette
présidence formellement le premier le 30
novembre
jusque là on travaille dans les
coulisses on le fait avec la présidence
péruvienne qui elle est officiellement
présidente jusqu'en jusqu'au 30 novembre
et donc on le fait est là pour beaucoup
de raisons d'abord pour pouvoir
travailler plutôt ce qu'on a commencé à
faire dès le mois de février et ensuite
pour s'associer à un pays en
développement écoutée respectée par part
disons les autres pays en développement
et cela nous permet de ne pas au fond ne
pas être vu simplement comme grands pays
européens qui voudraient éventuellement
imposer ses vues donc on essaie de ceux
de cette façon de se prémunir contre le
syndrome qui a très largement affecté la
présidence danoise à copenhague
donc l'association étroite avec le pérou
fait partie à mon sens des chances de
succès qu'on accumule pour paris du
capital politique on essaie de créer
pour paris la deuxième le deuxième chose
qu'on fait aussi du point de vue de la
technologie des négociations outre le
fait de mobiliser notre réseau c'est
d'organiser des réunions informelles de
négociation où on essaye de faire
rapprocher les points de vue on l'a fait
à lima en mars à paris en mai on va
encore continuer en juillet et en
septembre et là à des à différents
niveaux au niveau des chefs de
négociation des négociateurs ou des
ambassadeurs ou au niveau des ministres
donc on a eu un moment important la
cciad dix jours maintenant se confond un
peu les dates je dois voyager trop mais
à petersburgh à berlin
où la chancelière merkel et président
hollande comme vous l'avez vu ont conclu
les travaux de ce dialogue de petersberg
où on a vu à la fois que les choses
commençaient à devenir sérieuses c'est à
dire il y as et c'est évident une
volonté d'aboutir à paris il y encore
une fois vraiment le souhait d'y arriver
est de montrer par ses contributions
nationales l'attachement à cet accord
collectif et donc de lui donner ce
caractère universel mais maintenant nous
rentrons dans la phase difficile où
chacun évidemment ferme un peu les
positions parce que on doit discuter des
choses difficiles lesquels sont elles
ces choses difficiles elles sont d'abord
ces grands points politiques non résolus
au fond ils sont au nombre de 4 4 ou 5
le premier c'est cet objectif de 2
degrés est ce qu'on arrive à à lui
donner un peu de chair un peu de concret
2° qu'est ce que ça veut dire alors on a
essayé 1 en 2010 en 2009/10 arrivé 2
degrés est et proxy comme on dit une
approximation pour ne pas avoir un
chiffre de réduction absolue des
émissions mondiales à l'échelle 2050 à
l'horizon 2050 ou bien pour ne pas
traduire ça en terme de concentration
des émissions à un chiffre de
concentration des émissions dont 2
degrés en se référant scénarios du giec
était une manière de contourner
l'obstacle alors on va garder cet
objectif
la labellisation formel c'est essayer de
contenir les températures entre 1.5 et
en dessous de deux degrés s'est pas
revendications notamment des petites
villes et des pays africains mais aller
plus loin vers cet objectif vous avez
sans doute entendu dire soit le
président de la république soit laurent
fabius soit d'autre il faudrait essayer
de dire on est à zéro émission net à la
fin du siècle où l'idée encore qu'on
doit éventuellement réduire les
émissions la commission européenne
propose le chiffre de - 60 % des
émissions mondiales par rapport à 2010
donc on a plusieurs versions pour
essayer d'indiquer quelque chose de
concret qui pourrait servir de guide
donc pas d'accord là dessus pour
l'instant en grande partie parce que on
a un problème de très simple d'une
équation à qui pourrait être une
équation à une inconnue
2° au fond sa correspondance quand même
à une certaine concentration des
températures si on sait que les pays
développés sont prêts à réduire leurs
émissions long tout s'annonçait déjà
2009 de 80 à 95% d'ici 2050
la seule inconnue qui restent à
l'équation c'est la réduction des
émissions du côté des pays en
développement et c'est ça qui fait
problème donc difficulté de donner des
chiffres parce que donnait un chiffre de
résultats 450 particules par million ou
un chiffre de réduction des émissions
mondiales par soustraction et parce
qu'on sait ce que des pays développés se
sont engagés à faire était déjà
ambitieux et bien ça donne le reste du
chemin à parcourir pour les autres
émetteurs et notamment évidemment au
premier de la chine et l'inde
assez vite derrière elle donc premier
point difficile on a plusieurs réponses
à cela on essaie de trouver des formules
peut-être pic des émissions le plus tôt
possible
l'idée que l'on pousse l'idée qui
progresse beaucoup quittent une idée qui
vient de la france de pousser chaque
pays a volontairement décrire son
scénario d'évolution économique
compatible avec 2 degrés d'ici 2050 non
pas sous une forme d'engagement solide
mais plutôt d'une vision pour aussi
faire rentrer dans les esprits et puis
regardez qu'est ce que ça suppose comme
transformation problèmes technologiques
etc mais donc c'est sur la table le
deuxième grand sujet c'est évidemment
les finances puisque à la fois on sait à
copenhague en 2009 puis en 2010 plus
formellement engagé du côté des pays
développés à trouver 100 milliards
financés du nord vers le sud de façon
publique et privée le développement
sobres des pays en développement d'ici
2020 qu'on a beaucoup de difficultés
aujourd'hui encore à fournir exactement
qu'est ce qu'on fait déjà et plusieurs
estimations qui sont qui ont été publiés
notamment par la banque mondiale disant
que la financement public est de l'ordre
de 37 millions de 37 milliards par an
aujourd'hui
donc il faut pourrait augmenter quand
même 7 ses financements et deuxième
question comment est-ce qu'on reconnaît
identifie le financement privé qui
s'investit aussi dans les objectifs
climatiques dans les pays en
développement
tout ça fait partie de la discussion ce
qui est certain c'est que ce qu'ils
obtinrent d'ici paris c'est une
compréhension commune de ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui de ce qu'on compte une
trajectoire et semblable d'augmentation
des finances publiques et privées d'ici
2020 et sans doute spécificité de ce
qu'on doit consacrer notamment au sujet
de l'adaptation changement climatique
ont conçu g et en particulier des pays
les plus pauvres
on a deux troisième grand sujet de débat
qui est la question de kelly à la
promesse que je disais sur les
contributions une si ces contributions
sont insuffisantes ce qu'elles sont
quelles seront très probablement ce qui
est normal comment est ce qu'on fait
pour les réviser à la hausse comme en
reste que avant 2030 ou avant 2025 on
instaure un mécanisme de revues
d'augmentation de ces contributions pour
qu'on se mettre sur cette fameuse c'est
cette ou ces fameuses trajectoire
compatible avec 2 degrés et là on a tout
un débat très difficile pour instaurer
ces cycles soit de façon mécanique soit
de façon plus flexible et là on a des
difficultés notamment
la chine est résistante à l'idée d'un
accord qu'on verrait régulièrement
3 troisième sujet difficile la
vérification et la mesure des progrès
des uns et des autres alors tout le
monde est d'accord sur le fait qu'il
faut un mécanisme de vérification et de
rapportage la nature de cette de cette
obligation le degré d' ingérence dans
les affaires intérieures pour vérifier
que les chiffres sont bien les bons font
évidemment l'objet du débat
et quatrièmement la grande question est
au fond est ce que on a les mêmes règles
pour tout le monde
ou est-ce que les mêmes obligations pour
tout le monde
ou quelle est la nature et le degré de
la différenciation entre pays développés
et pays en développement sur ses
obligations
je veux pas être trop longue donc je
vais m'arrêter bientôt on a donc devant
nous un peu moins de 6 mois les
négociations formelles à la fin la
semaine de sept semaines qui vont
démarrer qui sont alors j'ai beaucoup
dit il faut accélérer le tempo parce que
nous voulons du côté de la présidence
française
à voir dès octobre quand même les
grandes lignes de ce que peut être la
corde on ne pas attendre le moment de
paris pour cela il faut accélérer le
rythme donc que les messages
d'accélération sont très intentionnelle
ils ont été repris à différents niveaux
d'abord par le président de la
république ensuite par le fabuleux ces
jeux le relais tant que je peux pour
dire il faut qu'on octobre ont soif ou
est-ce qu'on va qu'on est les grands
éléments du paquet du paquet politique a
finalisé à paris il y aura un moment
important du g7 de juin parce que la
chancelière merkel veut faire de ce g7
sous présidence allemande un important
moment pour le climat notamment du point
de vue financier il y aura d'autres
moments importants en parallèle de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
où françois hollande et ban ki moon le
secrétaire général vont réunir un
certain nombre de chefs d'état pour
donner l'impulsion finale et nous aurons
avant le g20 une grande réunion à lima
en octobre pour traiter du sujet
financier cela avant la coop de décembre
il ya un agenda en parallèle que sur
lequel je voudrais pas revenir parce que
sinon ce serait trop long mais on suit
donc une série à la fois de conférences
de mobilisation pour mobiliser les
entreprises
vous l'avez vu la semaine dernière à
paris il y aura d'autres étapes avant
paris de cette mobilisation des
entreprises soit sur les engagements
individuels soient les engagements des
feuilles de route sectorielle soit sur
les engagements en matière d'innovation
technologique
même chose du côté des autorités locales
même chose du côté des acteurs
financiers
donc ce que vous avez vu à paris il va
se reproduire pour d'autres acteurs à
lyon en juillet ensuite en septembre à
new york en octobre à lima comme je le
disais et sans doute avec d'autres
points de rendez vous en octobre à
genève ou à paris se font aussi partie
de ceux de ses autres agenda de
négociations qu'on poursuit pour que
lier un peu à la fois un momentum
politiques et beaucoup de beaucoup de
soutien
beaucoup de courage donné au
gouvernement pour s'engager davantage je
vous propose qu'à ce stade je m'en
tienne la queue alors je n'ai pas
répondu
enfin façon je pourrais pas répondre à
toutes vos questions en détail mais je
le ferai peut-être que tu as plus petit
peu par p type sur la situation
particulière notamment les pays
africains qui sont à la fois très engagé
plus engagés qu'auparavant plus
coordonnée qu'auparavant d'ailleurs qui
préparent des contributions
il ya des stratégies différentes mais la
plupart des pays africains sont engagés
dans une préparation je pense au sénégal
à l'ethiopie au kenya bien sûr à
l'afrique du sud mais aussi la
république centrafricaine a bien
d'autres au mozambique en fin donc on va
les voir arriver au courant de l'été la
préoccupation pour eux c'est moi la
réduction des émissions que l'adaptation
aux changements climatiques mais aussi
de s'engager du point de vue notamment
des sources d'énergie vers les énergies
propres et non pas de faire le moins
possible le passage par le charbon ou le
pétrole de faire tant que faire se peut
des programmes d'efficacité énergétique
suffisamment tôt pour le réduire le
poids du coût de l'énergie dans l'eure
dans leur croissance économique pour
notamment pour ceux qui ont évidemment
qui n'ont pas de ressources minières ou
pétrolières propre donc une mobilisation
assez grande des pays africains à une
attente très grande des pays africains
sur l'adaptation au changement
climatique et la réponse que les pays
développés notamment du point de vue
financier feront un grand sujet
agricoles forêts aussi qu'il faut pas
oublier pour ces pays qui est très
important est ce qu'on peut avoir une
agriculture adaptée aux changements
climatiques
on va y avoir moins de précipitation
dans beaucoup de zones trop de
précipitation dans d'autres et que cette
agriculture cuisse faire suffisamment
vivre les populations locales pour que
l'on n'ait pas besoin de continuer cette
déforestation qui est aussi un grand
problème dans beaucoup de zones donc on
a un petit peu mon lancement de balle
et puis évidemment je suis toute ouïe
sur vos questions quant à donner la
parole à jean bignon qui est le
président du groupe de travail sur les
négociations climatiques qui paie
ensuite je suis rapporteur de la
commission des affaires étrangères au
sila le souhait légitime d'intervenir et
après d'autres
d'autres membres des deux commissions
qui on part dans l'intention de
s'exprimer
merci monsieur le président merci madame
l'ambassadrice
pour vous pour vos propos que j'ai
trouvé rassurant parce que j'avais été
un peu inquiet en lisant dans la presse
récemment que vous aviez l'air plus
pessimiste que vous ne l'avez été
aujourd'hui vous avez été très positive
et c'est vrai que c'est encourageant
quand on mène une négociation aussi
difficile il ya probablement des jours
avec et des jours sans et peut-être le
juron vous avez interrogé
vous n'aviez pas le train que vous avez
la plupart du temps à ça peut être
tactique aussi
alors moi j'ai trois questions un peu de
technique au fond parce que vous avez
dit vous avez déjà rappelé beaucoup de
choses vous avez parlé du dialogue de
petersberg qui n'est pas une expression
qu'on voit souvent dans la négociation
internationale bon je sais que c'est une
négociation qui fait c'est une enceinte
qui a été menée créé par les allemands
en 2010 donc après l'échec de de
copenhague pour renouer le dialogue j'ai
vu qu'il y avait une 35 pays qui
participaient mais qu'elle est qu'est-ce
qui différencie
petersburgh du reste de l'année goa par
le pouvoir d' influence de la
chancelière
c'est une première question deuxième
question j'ai vu que le le prince albert
de monaco c'était avait sollicité alors
ça va paraître très bizarre ce que je
vais dire mais quelqu'un absent des
négociations ils soient réintégrés c'est
l'océan vous avez présidé l'iddri très
longtemps avec beaucoup de détermination
et vous avez mis l'océan sur le devant
de la scène à bien avec beaucoup de
détermination
ce qui nous vaut probablement
aujourd'hui d'avoir à l'assemblée
générale des nations unies ce 2
septembre une renégociation d'un bout de
montego bay qui manquait au grand large
le prince s'inquiètent de ne pas voir
l'océan dans la négociation c'est vrai
qu'on est attendu que c'est sûr
réduction des gaz à effet de serre et
les réductions de gaz à effet de serre
on les imagine comme une donnée
terrestre et il ya toute une partie de
l'opinion publique notamment qui se
retrouvent dans la plateforme océan et
climat qui était un peu triste de ne pas
voir
la prise en compte de l'océan comme un
formidable puits de carbone et comme un
formidable émetteurs de l'oxygène j'ai
participé hier matin encore et que
madame madame guèye gaye qui est une
chercheuse bien connu du crs que vous
connaissez bien
qui regrette ça aussi donc peut-être
pourriez nous donner un mot
d'explication encore une fois que je ne
juge pas il ya un parti pris qui a été
donnée mais pourquoi ne pas se donner la
chance de mettre l'océan dans la dans la
partie et puis peut-être un point encore
rapide
j'ai entendu dire qu'il ya des gens qui
étaient qui joue un rôle je vais je les
cités parce qu'on s'était les chinois en
particulier qui joue un peu derrière le
rideau
c'est à dire qu'ils ont une stratégie
qui consiste à dire on est un pays
émergent c'est très difficile pour nous
et c est en même temps derrière le
rideau qui est la traduction de
l'expression anglaise
ils jouent un rôle très puissant en
matière de réflexion industrielles
nouvelles technologies innovations sans
sens là sans la dévoiler iter qui jouent
aux pauvres devant et derrière ici se se
construise un avenir dont je me réjouis
d'ailleurs pour le peuple chinois et
pour le monde entier
mais qui est un peu ambiguë par rapport
au rôle qu'ils prétendent jouer sur le
devant de la scène
est ce qu'on parle de ça est ce que ça
fait partie du jeu d'un sujet dans l'est
dans les négociations voilà très
rapidement trois points d'ender
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
étrangères
merci monsieur le président madame là
l'ambassadrice je remercie allah pour le
coup je suis plutôt de nature
extrêmement optimiste là en revanche je
le serai peut-être un peu moins je suis
effectivement rapporteur de la com de
du rapport de la commission des affaires
étrangères sur le dérèglement climatique
et précisément sur l'impact géopolitique
nous avons eu un certain nombre
d'auditions depuis le depuis quelques
temps et un certain nombre de
scientifiques y en ait ils sont plutôt
si je puis dire à l'âme alarmiste non
pas sur le seuil de 2 degrés dont vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure mais plutôt
sur une échelle de 4 degrés celsius
voire même certains sont déjà sur des
logiques de 4 à 6 degrés donc je je note
avec intérêt que les négociations porte
simplement sur une limitation à ne pas
dépasser les 2 degrés donc quid de ce
delta qui est pas du tout une une
hypothèse mais une réalité qui a été
développé à plusieurs reprises par en
tout cas dans l'ensemble des auditions
qu'on a pu avoir ça c'est ma première
remarque et j'aurai trois questions est
ce que vous pensez
si on reprend l'accord conclu entre les
etats-unis et la chine en septembre ou
octobre dernier qui à eux deux
représentent à peu près 42 % du total
des gaz à elle des départs dans des
émissions de co2 est ce que vous
considérez que cet accord est plutôt une
opportunité plutôt un bon signe ou au
contraire est-ce que c'est typiquement
le genre d'accord qui peut mettre à mal
les négociations pour la coop 21
la seconde question un très justement
sur l'organisation vous avez dit à juste
titre qui convenait de mobiliser
l'ensemble des acteurs de notre société
particulièrement les entreprises
aujourd'hui nous savons à peu près que
dans les dix plus grandes entreprises
mondiales sur les 10 plus grandes parts
dont huit d'entre elles ont une activité
directement liés aux activités fossiles
comment vous arrivez à les mobiliser
justement puisque précisément l'objectif
de la cap 21 à l'encontre de leur
business plan puisque fondamentalement
leur structure économique et simplement
centrée sur les énergies fossiles et
encore une fois sur ces digues plus
grandes entreprises force est de
rappeler qu'il n'ya pas de banque
ça c'est ma deuxième question sur ma
troisième question en ce qui concerne le
le fond vert et éventuellement les aides
dédiées à un certain pays certain nombre
de pays en développement
il ya une ambiguïté sur la terminologie
puisque du en fonction du groupe auquel
on appartient on peut lui donner une
qualification juridique alors
soit l'aide est considéré par les
bailleurs de fonds comme étant une aide
et donc les bailleurs de fonds ont un
droit de regard sur la manière dont les
fonds sont utilisés soit si on est du
côté entre guillemets des pays qui se
considère comme étant victime de la
surconsommation du nord pour la faire
schématique soit cette aide est
considérée comme étant une dette de
cette pollution des pays développés et
dans ce cas ils n'ont pas le droit fin
il n'y a pas de raison que permettent et
autorise un droit de regard est ce que
cette notion est définitivement est-ce
que c'est des sujets sur lesquels vous
êtes travailler afin justement d'éviter
des interprétations qui demain seront
sujets à discussion et un blocage ou en
tout cas qui ne permettront pas des
avancées significatives pour lutter
justement contre le lait les comment
dire les gaz à effet de serre et enfin
j'avais dit 3 excusez moi j'avais une
quatrième question je finirai là dessus
un sujet qui me paraît extrêmement
important contenu donc et je reviendrai
sur mon introduction sur mon propos
plutôt sur un schéma à 4 degrés n'ont
pas deux donc avec comme conséquence
directe des déplacements de populations
extrêmement important nous avons eu un
certain nombre d'auditions sur lequel
nous avons posé la question de savoir si
la france se soucier avait réfléchi ou
en tout cas portaient le sujet de la
notion juridique soit de déplacé on
l'appellera comme on veut mais
simplement pour pour poser l'idée soit
de déplacés environnementaux soient de
réfugiés environnementaux soient de
réfugiés climatiques
il nous apparaît en tout cas clairement
à l'issue des différentes auditions que
nous avons pu avoir que la france n'a
pas tranché ce sujet et en ce qui me
concerne je m'excuse d'ailleurs pour mon
collègue cédric perrin qui avait une
contrainte
en ce qui nous concerne il nous semble
en tout cas qu'il est peut-être
important pour la france qu'elle se
saisisse de ce sujet puisque les
déplacés climatiques ou la définition
qu'on voudra bien en données sont pas
une lubie mais quelque chose qui ait
enfin un phénomène qui arrivera est ce
que la france n'a pas intérêt à
anticiper aujourd'hui nous sommes encore
un pays influent dans 20 ou 30 ans ça
sera peut-être pas le cas
est-ce qu'on n'a pas encore intérêt à
influer justement aujourd'hui apporter
ce sujet parce qu'en tout cas ce qui est
ressorti de nos différentes auditions
c'est que c'est un sujet qu'on évite
pour dérision en tout cas de politique
intérieure qu'on peut comprendre mais
c'est pas le débat d'aujourd'hui
je vous remercie
je n'aurais peut-être ajouter dans le
prolongement de ce qu'a dit ce desk
évoqué leila aichi à quel niveau de
dechy fra j'allais dire vous placez le
succès de cette conférence
on vient d'avoir l'expérience en avril
la conférence de l'onu sur les risques
naturels qui s'est soldée je crois vers
le 18 mars par un casier cheikh faye
avait une sympathique déclarations il y
avait aucun objectif chiffré il y avait
aucun financement et aucune sanction
comment dans le rôle qui est le vôtre
tentez-vous d'imposer ou en tous les cas
de faire accepter un certain nombre de
chiffrage précis de telle sorte que là
aussi on évite le danger des conférences
internationales qui se termine par des
belles déclarations mais qui n'ayant pas
d'objectif n'ayant pas de sanction est
l'occasion pour les pays en voie
développement n'ayant pas d'aidé
financière prévus aboutissent finalement
à pas grand chose très simple très
simple je vais prendre un peu dans
l'ordre ce dialogue de petersberg c'est
typiquement le la manière d'essayer de
au fond d'eux d'éclaircir les points
politiques que les négociateurs n'arrive
pas à trancher dans le processus
multilatéral habituel c'est la même
chose que ce qu'on fait lorsqu'on va
organiser d informelle au niveau
ministériel ou que les états unis
organisent en invitant au sein du forum
des économies majeures aussi au niveau
des chefs de délégations ou des héros
des ministres on a besoin de ce type
d'enceintes pour un peu vaincre
l'inertie du système multilatéral qui
est compliqué en essayant de dans un
dans des enceintes où on ne négocie pas
mais on essaie de se comprendre on
essaie d'identifier des convergences ou
de bien éclaircir les divergences
d'avancé pour qu'ensuite on traduisent
puisque il faut toujours se souvenir que
les négociations multilatérales ce sont
des négociations de juristes vous
parliez de l'océan et c'est ça et donc
dé négocier un texte juridique
connaissez les juristes et de leur
grande rigueur
c'est très compliqué non couvert très
précis
il faut au moins des monts ça y est les
concepts pour savoir si on peut trouver
la formule est donc d'où l'intérêt de
ces de ces enceintes plus politique qui
essaie de se dire bon au fond comment on
va trouver les 10 les différents
compromis donc c'est l'utilité
je pense que ç'a bien fonctionné cette
année aussi
c'est un bon petit une bonne
représentation de dix ans de la
diversité du pays s'est tassée en
général suffisamment divers pour qu'on y
retrouve les différents groupes de
négociation où les différentes
catégories de pays l'a peut-être la
difficulté c'est que les on a besoin
d'atterrir sur des sujets concrets on a
balayé un peu large mais ça a été au
fond la première discussions
ministérielles que nous avions depuis le
début de l'année donc de ce point de vue
elle a été très importante et la
chancelière avait laissé à la france
beaucoup de place pour donner notre
vision des choses
donc ça nous a été très utile qu'un
s'agissant des océans et le malheur qui
veut qu'ils soient des puits de carbone
qui est évidemment de dégrader
énormément la ciguë l'écosystème
océanique dans son entier à cause de ces
concentrations élevées dans l'atmosphère
je pense que à la fois ya beaucoup de
pays qui ont envie que on traite des
sujets des océans
il faut trouver la formule et c'est pas
simple les forêts au fond qui a été un
peu le premier écosystème qui a été
touchée de la question de la
désertification est un peu la même
enfin dans des problèmes très différents
mais au fond les forêts on l'a attaqué
des deux côtés c'était à la fois un
puits de carbone mais qu'on pouvait
éventuellement protégé puisque si on
évite la déforestation
on évite de perdre toutes ses codes
tonnes de carbone stockée accumulé puis
on permet de régénérer aussi cette forêt
et la question de l'océan c'est comment
est ce qu'on ferait dans cette
acidification comment est ce que
justement c'est pas l'océan qui est la
variable d'ajustement majeur qui a
rapidement vers une détérioration de la
faune et de la flore des gros enfin je
ne vous fais pas le tableau puisque vous
le connaissez très bien donc c'est à la
fois très important de parler des océans
et en même temps par quel biais en
attaque ça reste que c'est au fond la
conséquence de nos actions qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour protéger les océans est
ce qu'il ya des des choses qu'on peut
faire déjà il ya des choses assez
évidente mais qui sont l'exploitation du
sous-sol
on peut essayer de faire moins grave
mais quand même l'enjeu essentiel pour
les océans c2c de réduire les émissions
mondiales
c'est ça qu'il faut arriver à faire donc
ou bien tu accroître les capacités
d'absorption par d'autres fuites carbone
qui sont les sols ces deux problèmes en
grand sujet qui est en train d'émerger
heureusement par l'agriculture
et la fertilisation des sols qui
permettrait justement de soulager un peu
l'absorption des océans et aussi par la
meilleure gestion des forêts dont
caïazzo nous font tourner autour des
sujets océan parce que le sujet océans
pour l'instant c'est un sujet d' impact
du changement climatique
davantage qu'un sujet de solutions et
donc c'est à la fois un point important
et en même temps si on le mettait
n'importe où ce samedi rsa saint-pierre
à rien on parlerait de l'océan pour
parler de l'océan et j'en discute
beaucoup avec mes collègues du monde des
océans qui voudraient bien que le sur
ocean apparaissent partout et en même
temps on n'a pas encore trouvé comment
est ce que on traite cela autrement que
en essayant de se donner peut-être s'est
pas encore mûr mais ça pourrait l'être
peut-être en passant par les processus
scientifique de se donner des objectifs
en matière de au fonds de 7,2 cette
absorption ça pourrait être en revers
donc
donc on est quand même à réfléchir et
quelques papiers je crois qu'on en avait
publié à l'iddri à l'époque de se donner
un peu une vision mais mais je dois dire
que d'ici paris avant une mention y aura
une mention sur les océans à plusieurs
endroits une solution derrière un
objectif par exemple chiffré pour les
océans je pense que l'on n'en est pas
encore là alors sur sur cette question
chinoise s'est pas vraiment derrière le
rideau
la chine est le premier investisseur en
matière d'énergies renouvelables est
aussi premier investisseur en charbon
dans les centrales à charbon
cela dit elle est en train de prendre un
virage considérable puisque alors c'est
pas clair et on va voir si c'est dans la
contribution chinoise hong pas elle se
donne un objectif en matière de
limitation puisse de décroissance de la
consommation de charbon en chine
donc c'est un peu comme le débat enfin
très différemment c'est un peu comme le
débat nucléaire renouvelable ici en
france là le même type de débat en chine
il ya des gens qui disent quand même on
a cette ressource
pourquoi lagache et on sait faire c'est
ça qu'a fait le gros de notre
industrialisation pourquoi commencer à
faire quelque chose d'autre et d'autres
qui disent mais au contraire bon c'est
la pollution locale enfin on peut
trouver vous prenez le débat aux états
unis enfin on a quand même beaucoup de
parallèles
donc je dirais pas que c'est que la
chine veille à la fois faire elle-même
et parier sur l' économie sobre en
carbone
c'est absolument vrai et c'est ça le
changement fondamental qu'on a observée
depuis 2010 c'est ce changement de la
vision de la chine sur son économie en
2009 parlé d' économie sobre en carbone
en chine
c'était une menace aujourd'hui même les
négociateurs chinois disent ce qu'il
nous faut dans l'accord de paris
c'est quelque chose qui crédibilise qui
fasse qu on aille tous vers une économie
sobre en carbone
donc pour eux c'est une priorité il veut
pas y aller tout seul donc nous on
voudrait pas aller tout seul dans cette
direction là aussi pour exemple
compétitivité et d'intégration
d'économie mondiale donc c'est pas
derrière le rideau ce qui est ce qu'ils
veulent pas ce qu'ils essayent de
protéger le plus possible c'est leur
propre rythme leurs propres décisions et
donc ils veulent le moins d'obligations
internationales possible mais la
direction dans lequel ils vont elles est
pas contestable et d'ailleurs pas
brouiller on le voit à travers et les
décisions qui ont été prises
certainement la préparation du troisième
plan on va avoir quelque chose
d'intéressant il y aura la contribution
chinoise probablement moins de juin et
et des éléments très concrets de mise en
oeuvre déjà dans les décisions prises
pour le 13ème plan qui courent donc de
2016 à 2005 ans plus tard donc à de 2021
on aura les mesures assez précise fin
août
donc je pense je le clan du sérieux de
encore une fois dans un débat féroce
parce qu'en chine
tous portent sur quel est le taux de
croissance sur lequel on parie pour les
15 prochaines années ce qui est un sujet
éminemment politique
c'est un sujet d'économie c'est un sujet
est ce qu'on dit qu'on va être à 10% par
an et que tout repose donc sur cette
course effrénée aux 10% par an où est-ce
qu'on est à cinq ou est-ce qu'on a six
soissons et 1,7 et c'est ça qui fait des
scénarios chinois en réalité presque
tous les instituts de recherche chinois
y compris pense que les émissions
mondiales peuvent chinoises peuvent se
réduire à partir de 2025
mais ils ne veulent pas s'engager à ça
parce que s'engager à ça ça voudrait
dire déjà faire un pari taux de
croissance relativement faible pour
l'instant donc le découplage tant qu'on
n'est pas complètement sur le découplage
peut s'affirmer de plus en plus entre
énergie consommation d'énergie et
particulièrement l'énergie fossile epide
la variable d'ajustement c'est le taux
de croissance du pib est donc il est
compréhensible que ça soit un peu
derrière le rideau parce que c'est juste
que c'est un sujet politique
super difficile encore une fois je me
réfère aux débats que qu'elle veut
beaucoup participé sur la transition
énergétique dire qu'on divise par deux
la consommation d'énergie française en
ça avait l'air de dire qu'on sacrifiait
l'économie française c'est exactement le
genre de débat encore une fois alors sur
cette question du du 4° que vous avez
posé madame hadji fois que vous avez
posé vous constatez que les le lait les
conclusions de nos collègues de l'ipc
sans fin du giec et des climatologues
français vous avez sûrement auditionné
se fonde quand même sur des
contributions qu'ils sont enfin c'est le
'business as usual' de maintenant c'est
5,4 degrés 4 au dessus de 4 encore une
fois il faut voir ce que nous donne la
récolte de ces premières contributions
on sera à ce moment là encore une fois
c'est une trajectoire etc des
probabilités 1 c'est pas des
déterminations mécanique plutôt quelque
chose entre 3 et 4 3 3 degrés au 3° et
je pense que enfin tout l'objectif de
l'accord c'est de se donner un mécanisme
pour le faire que cette trajectoire qui
passent plutôt qu'ils nous donnent plus
de 50% de chances de probabilités d'être
au-dessus de 3 degrés en stabilisé
puisque c'est pas une date précise que
que ceci se passe c'est effectivement de
prévoir ces mécanismes rouen va
accentuer l'effort et pourquoi on
accentuerait l'effort dans le futur
c'est pour des raisons assez simple on
voit qu'on y arrive de les technologies
coûte de moins en moins chères et tout
le monde le fait et donc il ya un
intérêt à le faire
donc oui il faut à la fois voir si des
contributions qui sont proposés font
déjà faire une changement ça c'est le
premier constat très important est ce
que ce changement est quand même
significatif
ou est-ce qu'au fond c'est pas très
différent de ce que craignent nos
collègues hématologue en disant c'est le
'business as usual' et celui là
aujourd'hui quand on regarde ce qui se
passe est nommé à quatre degrés dont
première chose et deuxième chose comment
on relève
l'ambition de cet accord donc c'est ça
le succès de paris
il n'est pas gagné ce succès se
succèdent paris c'est au minimum d'avoir
un mécanisme qui nous permet de revenir
de faire le constat de où on en est de
conserver l'objectif global est de se
donner d état par lequel on va arriver
et ses étapes c'est pas juste seulement
de se revoir tous les cinq ans pour dire
on fait mieux c'est de mettre en place
ce qu'il faut en matière
d'investissement de recherche et
développement sur les technologies
en matière de financement international
on y arrive donc sa dépose de beaucoup
des moyens qu'on appelle des moyens de
mise en oeuvre de la de la convention
donc le avoir une chance 50% de chance
au moment où 60% de chances de vie
arriver à ces deux degrés ne pas les
dépasser plus tôt c'est quand même aussi
tous ses moyens de mise en oeuvre qui va
falloir éclaircir dans la cour de paris
voilà pour cette audition de laurence
tubiana ambassadrice chargée des
négociations climatiques elles étaient
auditionnés par les sénateurs des
commissions des affaires étrangères et
du développement durable cela dans le
cadre de la préparation de la coop 21 la
21e conférence des nations unies sur le
changement climatique qui se tiendra à
paris à la fin de l'année vous pouvez
toujours voir et revoir toutes les
auditions sur notre site publicsenat.fr
très bonne fin de journée sur les
chaînes parlementaires
c'est un véritable trafic d'êtres
humains et à des actes de barbarie que
se livrent des bédouins du sinaï en
toute impunité
ils kidnappent des réfugiés d'erythrée
les tortures et raquettes on suit leurs
familles un document inédit est édifiant
voyage en barbarie ce soir à 22h30 sur
public sénat